>> Image processing involves using tools
and code to analyze and manipulate Images.
In Data Science and AI related projects,
Python is the prevalent language
for working with data of all kinds.
So how can we use Python to work with image data?
Well, here's our image which to
the computer software is represented as
a three-dimensional matrix of pixel values.
In Python, Matplotlib is often
the Ggplot2 package for dealing with
data visualizations like charts and plots,
but you can also use it to read write and display image files.
Then there's the Python Image Library or
Pill and a particular a Fork of that package known as Pillow.
This package contains a library of
useful Image Manipulation Functions
that enable you to work with a wide range of image types.
OpenCV is another well-established library
for Python based Computer Vision Programming.
Scikit-Image is yet another library
that's particularly useful for applying
statistical and mathematical functions
to image data for analysis and modelling.
Now, you might use some or all of
these packages for various image related tasks.
But at the end of the day, an image is just an array of numbers.
The NumPy Library is great
for working with numeric data structures.
In fact, it turns out that a NumPy array is
the perfect format to share image data
across all of the available image processing packages,
and acts like a common currency that you can use to
exchange images between different libraries,
so that you can use the specific functionality you need.